[Musique]
mais calculé deux ans ma vie m'a
ce chien la sombre merde 20h et la
haine c'est trop la haine et met
doucement ça va aller tu va m'expliquer
ce qui s'est basé a par contre décroché
le téléphone tu m'as fait partout on
vient on va voir un peu tu veux boire
quoi la vodka sobotka et deviennent ce
que j'ai ramené
d'un vote
moi je suis grave vous allez vous étiez
millions à non non non non et épanouie
ont dansé plus gros fils de que je
connaisse puis jus de fruits non sec on
va se passer quoi bon je crois qu'à
l'heure actuelle je la meuf la plus
connue de france laisse tomber j'ai
l'impression d'être une femme de
footballeur mais genre tu es femmes de
footballeurs amateurs genre avec zéro
bnf lors van damme voleurs tiger je te
jure ce patron du coucou est à capter
quoi en gros jeudi dernier blazy part à
son entraînement de foot comme sam
le soir moi je me posais tout et je vois
que ce coup dont il a oublié son
téléphone sera table basse et moi je
sais que le gars sans son téléphone fait
un peu rémi sans famille tu vois du coup
gentil bouffonne que je suis je fais
quoi je vais dans son téléphone cherche
le numéro de son patron bio pour le
prévenir tu vois pas ce qu'ils jouent
avec lui je suis là cherche le nom et où
je l'appelle ça sonne ça décroche et la
meuf
all have you long arrêt cardiaque perdre
de vue commence à trembler tout je
raccroche
je regarde le téléphone comme ça je
reste bloqué pendant 2 minutes sur ma
photo sur son d'écran d'accueil
de merde je suis comme une il
se passe plus rien dans mon cerveau chez
pas quoi faire ch en pls j'étais là
j'étais comme ça et vas-y l'âge même à
chialer mais comme une merde tu mérite
tellement presse à tonga pas pitié pour
plus tard parce que ça c'est que le
début en fait pendant 30 minutes je
chiale et je l'insultais à haute voix
est juste y aller je l'insultais autres
est une hystérique une psychopathe l'a9
bref au bout d'un moment je me calme
j'essaye de reprendre les esprits et
tout j'aime plus de larmes j'ai même
plus d'un sultan stock j'ai plus rien je
retourne dans son téléphone et là on
fait tilt je me rends compte que son
pote que j'ai appelé rubio c'est rubio
en majus hull mais il ya aussi un
roupillon minuscule est l' intuition de
bataille commence à parcourir tout son
répertoire comme ça comme une folle je
fais tous les prénoms de ses meilleurs
potes c'est et neuf sur mon six d'entre
eux y avoir double en majuscules
mais quelle technique de chiens n y
avait pas de quoi sont elles mêmes mots
a même pas il s'en bat les couilles ce
chien rien pas de code rien témoin un
jour je me rappelle même qui m'a sorti
un bébé tu peux fouillé dans mon
téléphone quand tu veux moi j'ai rien à
cacher je t'aime dans un couple si a pas
de confiance et arrière elle s'appelle
conduire sera rien mais les hommes je te
dis sous espèces animales zeebo neuf
mois je suis laïque sous téléphones dans
les mains et tout je suis pas bien je me
dis mais n'est-ce pas possible ça d'être
un cauchemar georges rêves ses fautes
choix je me dis tu sais quoi pour en
avoir le coeur net eh ben je vais faire
tous les doublons un parent je veux
appeler tous les doublons en majuscules
je suis là je les appelle et meuf à
chaque fois quand je te dis à chaque
fois c'est à chaque fois c'est une
oeuvre qui décroche et en plus une fois
sur deux la pelle avec un surnom merde
genre mon lapin chatons baby chez pas
quoi l énergie ne suis pas dans les
nerfs monte mais je prends sur moi je
continue d'appeler le choix de descendre
dans ce répertoire c'est pas un moment
je vois quoi il ya un maman en
majuscules 101 me l'a osé ce fils
de de pète un câble mais pas de
retour en arrière possible c'est là
vraiment c'est la goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder le vase diakhaté j'appelle le
numéro une meuf décroche et l'âge l'anc
lens mais pendant deux minutes non stop
sans respirer et je suis largement cette
fatalité que vaut le 2 mai gamer que
teva t'as pas honte d'être une traînée
un écoute moi bien je connais des gens
je vais te retrouver et je vais nique et
toute ma vie je vais ta vie à toi
et ta famille tu as compris des morts
des douilles de l'ancienne comme ça et
me lie à une petite voix qui me l'a
109 je reconnais la voix de sade baronne
non mais de saddam et l'asb qui touchera
cross de démarrer car tu sais pas quoi
faire et touchant pls peuvent t la
meilleur je t'aime ta gueule tu n'as pas
envie d'être dans ma liste est horrible
genre je me dis mais je fais quoi je la
rappelle je la rappelle pas là rappelle
ce parti dans un autre pays fait quoi en
fait
je la rappelle pour m'excuser je suis
dit oui je suis désolé tout en fait avec
votre fille ça n'a pas très bien en ce
moment j'ai cru qu'ils me tromper mais
est ce que ça peut rester entre nous
tous
douze jours j'avais tellement seul et le
pire c'est qu'elle a visé non mais pas
inquiet je pense que tu te trompes est
tous vraiment y'a rien parlez vous ça va
s'arranger écoutez moi je suis là je dis
oui alors que je suis encore en train de
compter les maîtresses de mon mec genre
sur les doigts de maman tu vois tu t'en
mets l'enfer et weis 10 raccroche avec
elle est tombée je suis là comme kaunas
je me dis attention le parcours de
vitesse j'étais un tournevis michael
t'es même pas prêt le soir ils rentrent
moi je fais quoi je fais semblant
d'aller dormir parce que j'ai pas envie
de voir ça sale gueule de merde mais lui
c'est pas que suis dans la préparation
de ma bande et en bref le lendemain j'ai
envie texto simple et efficace est prêt
à vous je vous dit vous n'êtes pas prêt
lorsque je vais voir un territoire bouge
toi les oreilles route va de cloche dans
le jean direct live tous les ans
auparavant
vendredi georges du taf je vais boire un
verre avec le frédo toi je reçois un
texto d'emilie et me dit quoi j'ai pu y
ait d'autres femmes qui tenait la tête
de ma mère au début je me dis donc c'est
bizarre je crois que les bluffs lama
futur alors je vais dire donc je dirai
comment ça tu fais dans mon téléphone et
tout laisse moi vivre toi et tu sais
quoi je vais boire une bière avec le
frédo si tu tiens vraiment à en parler
ce soir voilà
tu rigoles ou quoi en deux secondes je
reçois un message qu'est venu une photo
de son ordi est aps 5 dans un sac
poubelle dont
il a répondu je suis là dans des
techniques et belle à la corrida petit
chien vit ma mère elle sait comment te
parler et aval du coup j'ai un mauvais
pressentiment
voyant pas mais
je fais quoi je saute dans la gauche
trace directe à la part j'arrive devant
ma porte est en répétition dans ma tête
shlomo simus caussinus racine carrée de
vie je prépare mes meilleurs disques est
comme bill gates est bon
j'ouvre la porte
elle est là dans le couloir postiches et
comme un videur frérot la mâchoire
serrée comme ça elle avait pris en photo
et là quand je la vois gros gens proches
le mode actor studio et l'allemand claus
son mas del torchio trois mâts par an
contre casse les couilles non
seulement le livre de la semaine faut
que tu me le buzz et quoi maintenant la
genre tu fous dans mon téléphone ces
nouveaux ce truc là c'est ça
n'est même pas calculé j'ai tracé comme
ça vers le salon strass race track lui
me suis là d'air comme un chien en train
de brailler encore féminin pour faire un
film est en fait six pompes faire chier
c'est ça
ouah ouah son canapé ledger tout
installer sans que mme huff que j'ai
tiennent ces deux derrière
j'ai buggé windows xp sa grand-mère aux
bobos et quoi lasser jugement dernier ou
quoi il rigolait il a rigolé il s'est
tapé une barge après ça se voyait qu'il
n'était pas besoin qu'il était dans le
mal et où qui savait pas gérer la
situation je comprends pas je serais tu
avais rien à cacher frère j'étais baiser
mais je me suis dit allez vas-y c'est
pas le moment de perdre l'appareil je
vois pas bb je te jure je n'ai jamais
trompé avec ses goules les seuls que
j'ai touché on n'était même pas ensemble
ah ouais quittez pas touchés ici vous
étiez pas ensemble nazim tu veux quoi
toi est bon coeur la 7e place moi
t'expliquer mes vieux on en parle tous
les deux comme des adultes c1 comme des
rois mais en voyant nature vous annonce
va rester là c'est toi sûreté mini coup
on va discuter on va tout écouté je ne
fais pas ça 9 là il me sort la pire
excuses des verts il dit vas-y c'est
très bien qu'il ya deux semaines on
était fâché tous les deux pas si j'étais
dans le mal de fous et j'avoue j'ai
déconné je suis allé la voir elle et je
regrette de malades est un géant on en
parle tous les deux bien arrête ce à
quoi il a tenté le mec genre grosse
landes menton anniversaire il ya quatre
mois vous est il fâché du temps mais tu
m'as jamais dit que ta vie de meuf elle
et moi tu nous as vu la même semaine tu
m'as envoyé des messages jusqu'à hier tu
étais vraiment une merde en fait c'est
un week-end en culotte au mythe est
complètement con quoi je comprends pas
si elles sont là c'est qu'on a parlé
avant c'est qu'on a discuté je comprends
pas pourquoi tu continues à temps font
ça dans ta mer de là à mentir non j'ai
pas su mais pour une fois dans ta ville
à
mes frais non pourquoi t'as pas fait
parce que fortios n'a
lui pas nous sauf que j'ai changé la
stratégie t'as vu je suis passé en 3-4-3
tout pour l'attack mal à capter qui
avait pas de majorité la cpt sur la tête
de ma mère en fait toi lac si tu fous là
là on a une fois il ya deux ans
mais tu galères sur la tête de 1 étoile
à toi j'ai mis six mois à me débarrasser
toi tellement tu marcelet comme never
espèce de folles bas et c'est quoi là tu
viens savourer ta petite vengeance la
taille par un mec à l'époque peut-être l
accabler complet la photo là même dont
je te parlais m'envoyer des 70 textos
par jour non seul oeil frères étrangers
embraye la même voie salle avec douvres
et été trop méchant en fait moi je suis
venu pour t'aider à la base en quoi tu
veux mais tu es mais oui mais du coup
mme ashton la vas-y figurants ok
elle se lève frérot elle part elle
commence à crier
une deux montres kill bill poteau a very
important
attention est l'un d'eux elles sont
encore sur mes côtes en mode grave tu
vois ce que je veux dire et là je fais
un scan acheter clip je vois une meuf je
me sais qu'il déjà hugo de kinder poteau
seul et unique expérience center
voilà pour ce que firent expériences
sexuelles de ma life poteau par le
talent à
vos écoutes meuf en gros elle faisait du
pôle zem
connaissez mon game bref on commence à
chauffer par texto depuis deux jours et
c'était un moment mtv passe à la baraque
moi je monte dans la gamme au centre pas
à m'envoyer j'espère que t'es pas
dérangé par les mouches à fruits mais
moi j'étais pas capté tant que j'ai pas
calculer je me suis dit vas-y devant le
cerveau congelé par l'envi de kent a
passé la seconde j'ai tracé tout droit
j'arrive sont anthony à perpète mon pote
déjà la meuf elle avait pas du tout la
même tête que sur les toffes à la tête
de foutu pour foutu julien de chez elle
et là les frères c'est ça tu vois les
mouches à bout mais là où la france est
salée mon chapeau c'est un élevage la
cuisine vers paul ii pas à ton frère où
je peux pas trop tu nous parce que la
meuf elle est archi mdsap un peu sur son
lit et où je me sens un peu mytho tu
vois ce que je veux dire jeudi un ami
que c'est un mauvais moment à passer tu
es là on commence à kehl
et là je me suis pas choqué
sauf que frère y avait une cage avec un
lapin dedans et je sais pas si c'est les
bruits les mouvements de l'as nika daou
ce qui s'est passé mais ça m'a stressé
chez pas il a commencé à me chier dessus
d'aragua
je recevais des billes de paintball de
merde en anglais sur mon cou y en a il a
touché mal à un cauchemar
est coupée et a fait quoi après tu
pourras entendre tous
justement la meuf là quand elle taille
l'autre folle sami un petit moment de
flottement un peu bizarre tu vois ce que
sa flotté
et l'agent cap une maryse ça je t'avais
parler d'elle à web tu t'entends des
biens et des deux frères la meuf voilà
un peu depuis le début tu vois un peu
tout seul dans son coin ça se voyait
cela faisait chier d'être là tu vois ce
que je vais dire hélas les frères je
tente le dernier coup de poker maryse je
sais que c'est pas le moment et j'ai pas
envie de me justifier tu vois ce qui
fait le plus de mal là-dedans cycle
c'est avec toi je devrais être un mais
je fais une déclaration d'amour oui non
peut-être de ma mère devant hemingway tu
devrais me boudait young question
raconte toi et baissera pas en quoi elle
va zy pas trop vers ta grande bouche des
mythos la laisse moi par les
bas-normands l'écoutent pas la trompe
pas ce que ça marche pas entre nous
ça le fait pas on dans la vie sexuelle
month franchement je te le dis j'ai le
som ne pas avoir eu les couilles de la
quitter avant parce que c'est avec toi
que j'ai envie d'être plus un mécano
kuyssche 2009 mais j'étais en pagaille
gts j'étais débordé je comprenais pas ce
qui m'arrivait c'était trop gros tas
capter ce n'est pas l'autre but a
commencé à lui parler que de la
tendresse et où les trouver dans une
situation mais toi ma place c'est hyper
gênant c'est que ça soit gênant je m'en
bats les couilles de tous un mois moi je
sais juste que je t'aime c'est tout mais
un gars comme ça que je fais avant qu'il
fasse trop des gains mais j'avais envie
de lui rouler dessus à ce moment là puis
l'autre en plus ça commence à minauder à
lui lâche des justes c'est pas le moment
donc on a plus tard fait elle connaît ça
aurait été ma chatte ouais mais même à
ce moment là là quand elle a dit sa
décharge électrique dans mon corps la
vraie manger vrille et gère des mavs en
troisième et commence à plus tard mais
qu'est ce tu racontes toi mais tu es
comme quoi surtout qu'ils sont tagués
comme sous le label de tourner d'ici mai
par mois bien toi je suis pour rien
c'est un mec qui te trompe si je n'aime
pas être au mieux de vos en gros et en
fait j'ai même pas s'il devrait être là
parce qu'il ment pas quand il dit que
lui et moi on a eu de vrais échanges et
l'attend là je croyais que j'avais fait
un bond photos de zéro pointé mais les
techniques comme et les frérots à la
dégaine de son fidèle du monde ton foot
l2 on compare les messages c'est quoi
sur ton téléphone et dis moi quelle date
c'est à dire quoi on commence à sortons
de téléphone et 10 mois à quelle
date pas de quoi tu vas voir qu'on a
tout reçu
mariska pas faire ça ça la regarde pas
tout ce qu'il ya entre ma gueule toi ok
mais tu te vexant parce que moi j'ai
suédoise il cherche
par exemple le 6 avril quelle heure le 6
avril à 23h37 il m'a écrit je crois que
j'ai jamais autant aimé embrasser
quelqu'un que toi ma desjardins est en
vacances ça fait super plaisir c'est
quoi les meufs sortez vos téléphones et
regarder si vous a parlé ce jour là elle
commence à se montrer les messages que
je leur envoyer simultanément et tac tac
tac tac tac moi j'ai trop envie de toi
une heure du matin j'ai rien j'ai rien
s'y attendait lui avril tu élèves sont
uniques voilà moi j'ai 14 avril à 22h je
tiens plus je vais devoir plus j'ai
envie de toi là tout de suite juste de
toi agen tu fais quoi 22h32
pareil tu fais quoi 22h34 la dure voyant
dans tu fais quoi une autre meuf à 22h33
non mais il n'ya pas que c'est que ce
centre nous en fait par exemple le 2 mai
il m'a envoyé j'ai envie de passer mes
journées à t'embrasser je ne me lasse
pas de conter t'estimo grande beauté
mais attends espèce de grande bouffe on
attend à tan tan tan tan non parce que
toi tu crois trop la vie c'est titanic
tu vas te mange et on espère chelsea du
change voilà tenez j'aime que tu
embrasses et je veux passer mes journées
à côté des grains de beauté il ya six
mois pour mon anniversaire sur instagram
espèce de chien il renouvelle même pas
ces disquettes cette petite merde là
retour de flamme frères la warzone
retire de surchauffe abonnés dans tous
les sens vrai nom mais soit pas vexer
ans je te jure on est ensemble c'est lui
c'est une grosse merde c'est tout une
merde qu'ils savaient pas faire l'amour
en plus
vers l'amour toi tu es un couard 200 m
mon gars tu as que de la bouche et
encore tu sais même pas concernés non
mais d'ovcara n'y a même pas besoin de
chronos tu peux compter texte saint y de
y-3 y graver à mais ça y est on y de y
trop y
voilà comme ça on dirait qu'il a envie
de vomir
frère tu fais tapis avec une paire de
deux camps tout le monde voter car tu
vas te faire tomber dessus c'est sur une
méthode plus trop le cas mais il va
t'arriver des bricoles un jour même et
tu crois que chacun a mis 15 photo ay et
moi j'avais 30 mg on paie nos chalets
nash habitués à ce que je n'allais pas
laisser mme allumée toute la soirée sauf
qu'il ya une meuf la rose y elle
commencera à 10 heures et midi près
attendant si vite faire vraiment pas ton
installe est bien immobilier le bug un
peu de choix comprends pas trop mais le
monde sauf un tel jeu et l'autre frère
elle capte quoi en fait l amère quand
vous voyez des nues dans mon mec âge en
ramenant une victoire
aymeric serait un acteur là bas c'était
mon bac question a parlé sur un star et
je l'envoyais dénudement
non on a juste parlé on s'est parlé
c'est tout j'ai vraiment fais ce que tu
racontes là débute alors ta gueule a dit
un truc et c'est pour ça c'est la pub
qu'envoyer des nues dans mon ex car moi
je les crains mais on s'est séparés à
cause de ça emilie elle envoyait des
nude à son mec pendant qu'on était
ensemble pour emilie pris un très bon je
pouvais pas savoir qu'il avait une meuf
moi il m'a rien dit ouais ouais c'était
malheureux dit tout et on s'aidera gars
bronzé tous
incroyable tu es là tu organises mon
tribunal est une trompe études et
goûtent et là je m'étais vas-y bnf je
vais retourner le truc dans mon nom
c'est
un dieu tout frérot or qu'est-ce que je
m'en bats les couilles tu pouvais pas
savoir parce que moi je ferai savoir
aximum dû racler la vie de meuf c'est
exactement pareil d'ailleurs stosur
ferme ta gueule toi définitivement temps
émilienne transforme en dragon à deux
têtes poteau elle prend m'appelait
savait que face à deux volets alors je
fais quoi
la piste a trait aux minots tata l'airé
pour taper objet du csu des mecs de la
fnac frère
et elle commence toutes les deux à me
crier dessus comme des fous les quatre
salles et des gens dessous
je me suis mise dans un bourbier la main
pour un bon ballon tu pouvais pas savoir
mais meuf la probabilité de chances que
cette note jean habite chez moi elle
n'existe pas fait j'ai
un problème toi je te comprends de cap
et de son seul
fait quand même fait perdre un plan cul
à un mec tu
mais après tu as fait quoi du coup après
j'appelais maman faut tout
comment ça va
écoute sanitaires un petit maman minus
le gros qui sont convaincus qu'ils
disent et et de moi c'est la plus fidèle
des infidèles
et berthe a pas de cas d'attenté le toit
les frérots sac et techniques dedans ça
prouve que tu est irréprochable je suis
pas comme vous moi dès qu'un aliment
inconnu chelou qui appelle à retourner
mon phone devant magot comme un mec
radio cauet ce mec qui se répétaient
poids 1000 mais c'est lui qui le donnent
des comptes est banal
mais permet d'envoyer gueule ça a marché
pendant deux ans et que la technique
elle est opérationnelle
au final tu es triste ou pas je suis
marié à la rue poteau où je file à
l'envers les amis c'est ça merci google
à wenzhou heureusement que vous êtes là
vous nous en sommes qu au bac on se
connaît
cette histoire de bouffe on s'en fout
quoi là
[Musique]
je rêvais que plein ne te pas là pour me
juger mais pour être un avocat aux trois
quarts des trucs qui me remonte le moral
est mal vu par la morale je suis un
on n'aime pas ce biais moyens
ce qui est banal on préfère passer du
bien mal que tu vas bien pas mal on est
malade
mais si tout le monde est malade alors
ça va ya plus d aix millénaire que d'ex
claude à la vie c'est dramatique et
rigolo mais ça quand on bat à mort dans
une voiture qui fait des tonneaux
ce serait trop beau si tout le monde se
donner la main pour faire une ronde
autour de la terre mais pour la faire
c'est les pauvres cons dans la
merde c'est clair en tout le monde
pareil comme une bombe nucléaire
sur ces cas pas de problème il n'y a pas
de solution
[Musique]